[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ich euch jetzt vorlesen werde ist
das gespräch einer russischen soldaten
mutter mit ihrem sohn an der front in
der ukraine nur wenige minuten bevor
dieser start mein sohn wo bist du papa
will ein paket schicken der soldat
antwortet aber wie könnte man ein paar
kritiken mama ich bin in der ukraine wir
sind im krieg
so sieht es aus die meisten russen
scheinen nicht einmal zu wissen dass in
der ukraine ein krieg stattfindet
[Musik]
wir haben bei den recherchen für dieses
video mit vielen russen gesprochen die
sowohl in russland als auch in
europäischen union leben fast alle von
ihnen führen völlig surreal gespräche
mit jedem familienangehörigen die in
russland leben und dort von nichts
anderem als putins propaganda umgeben
sind es geht nicht nur darum dass sie
eine andere sichtweise auf den krieg
haben es ist ganz einfach so dass die
noch nicht einmal wissen dass kiew
bombardiert wird ihr habt bestimmt alle
die satelliten bilder gesehen die den 60
kilometer langen russischen kontrollen
deutlich von kiew zeigen nun die russen
haben ihn nicht gesehen sie lieben
buchstäblich in einem paralleluniversum
erst recht nachdem das folge gesetz am
vierten mehr als dieses jahres
verabschiedet wurde russisches parlament
beschließt gefängnisstrafen für fake
news die von krieg berichten das ist
richtig dies ist keine ukrainische
baganda es handelt sich um ein ganz
spezielles russisches gesetz ab dem
vierten jahr 2022 gilt die behauptung
russland befindet sich im krieg mit der
ukraine als fake news und als straftat
und die strafe für die behauptung dass
es überhaupt einen kritik kann bis zu 15
jahre gefängnis betragen gut einige von
euch werden denken das ist doch nicht
wirklich neu seit wann gibt es in
russland in meinungsfreiheit klar da
habt ihr recht der unterschied zu früher
ist aber dass zuvor ein journalist er
etwas sagt was dem regime nicht viel
offiziell nur eine geldstrafe riskierte
inoffiziell riskierte er natürlich von
der kreml mafia erschossen vergiftet
oder zumindest zusammengeschlagen zu
werden aber jetzt kann man dafür ganz
offiziell 15 jahre im gefängnis landen
statt krieg bekommen die russen in
diesen tagen auf allen kanälen also
sowas wie das folgende zu sehen
nach der darstellung des krimis befindet
sich russland mit niemandem im krieg es
führt lediglich eine spezialoperation
durch um neonazi terroristen in einem
nachbarland zu bekämpfen und was ist mit
den 200.000 russischen soldaten dass es
mit den panzern und den flugzeugen nach
dieser definition handelt es sich um
einen offenen krieg die abo team hatte
schon immer ein faible dafür seine
kriege auf zynische weise kleinzureden
die vielen russischen kommandos soldaten
und söldner welche die grünen besetzt
und im donbass einen brutalen
jahrelangen krieg ausgelöst haben nun ja
die waren alle nur im urlaub und die
frage ist warum eigentlich ich meine
scheint das nicht ein widerspruch zu
sein
[Musik]
auf der einen seite markiert putin seit
jahren den starken mann der tat für
patriotische begeisterung und
chauvinistische militarismus aus allen
kanälen rieselt er sein volk mit den
ruhmestaten seiner armee des großen
vaterländischen krieges der
überlegenheit russlands in allen
belangen sollte er ist nicht bilder von
den glorreichen russischen panzern
zeigen bkf einnehmen botschaften wie wir
sind die besten wir gewinnen diesen
krieg die ukraine wird bald teilen tod
dem feind lang lebe russland ja das
gegenteil ist der fall putin will den
krieg vor seinen bürgern verbergen und
die frage lautet warum eigentlich was
ist die sicht der russen auf das was
jetzt gerade passiert was steckt
eigentlich hinter putins propaganda
strategie wie ist diese auf die
russische mentalität abgestimmt und was
bedeutet dies für die zukunft die
russlands und die ganz europas wie
werden wir mit diesem russland
zurechtkommen und umgehen müssen heute
werden wir all diese fragen beantworten
und zwar wie immer zuerst durch einen
schnellen blick in die geschichte
[Musik]
von der geschichte zum narrativ
der russische staat war noch nie in
seiner geschichte in der lage solche
bedingungen zu schaffen das ganz normale
durchschnittsmenschen in ihm ein gutes
und zufriedenes leben führen können die
russische mehrheitsbevölkerung musste
immer unter besonders für europäische
verhältnisse unglaublich primitiven und
gewalttätigen bedingungen leben bis ins
18 jahrhundert hinein war privateigentum
in russland überhaupt nicht gesetzlich
durch den staat geschützt der
überwiegende teil der bevölkerung war
und frei was de facto sklaverei glich
die allermeisten russen durften ohne die
erlaubnis ihres herrn nicht umziehen
nicht heiraten und keinerlei
privateigentum besitzen daher
entwickelte sich die russische
mehrheitsgesellschaft ganz anders als
die übrigen europäischen völker von der
alphabetisierung ganz zu schweigen erst
im jahr 1861 endete dieser zustand der
unfreiheit und es konnte sich so etwas
wie ein rechtsstaat individueller rechte
und unternehmertum entwickeln allerdings
endete dies schon nach 50 jahren kaum
zwei generationen mit dem ersten
weltkrieg und der bolschewistischen
revolution eine viel zu kurze zeit damit
diese werte die gesellschaft nachhaltig
durchdringe denn danach folgten schlag
auf schlag der bürgerkrieg der
bolschewistische terror der zweite
weltkrieg und dann der aufbau der so
genannten entwickelten sozialistischen
gesellschaft inklusive des versuchs der
schaffung eines neuen menschen dh die
entwicklung individueller freiheiten
hatte null chance wie der politische
noch wirtschaftlicher noch kulturelle
nach dem fall des kommunismus über den
wir vor kurzem ein eigenes video gedreht
haben dass ich euch verlinken werde gab
es dann für wenige jahre die hoffnung
die russische gesellschaft könne all
diese dinge irgendwie nachholen nur ist
dies leider nicht passiert über die
genauen ursachen dieses scheiterns der
moderne in russland werden wir übrigens
ein eigenes video drehen genauso wie
über den russen welche den sprung in die
geschafft haben und nun das land in
scharen verlassen da gehst also bitte
nicht das auto und das glöckchen um
diese sehr interessanten videos nicht zu
verpassen aber gut aus all diesen
gründen sind wir heute da wo wir sind
und ich weiß was viele von euch denken
weil wir so alle politik sagt jedoch
total voreingenommen nato trolle dieses
video ist pure ukrainische propaganda
nun nichts könnte weiter von der
wahrheit entfernt sein in der tat haben
wir für die recherchen zu diesem video
fast nur russische quellen was du jetzt
sehen wirst ist buchstäblich das was
normale russen im fernsehen sehen und
damit uns niemand vorwerfen kann wir
würden voreingenommenen übersetzung
anfertigen zeigen wir die klicks im
original mit untertiteln und nebenbei
bemerkt vielen dank an swetlana kitschig
und atem vom economy kanal die uns bei
der übersetzung der videos geholfen
haben was so jetzt sehen was wird zum
beispiel kindern in hessischen schulen
gezeigt um zu erklären was eigentlich
vor sich geht
wenn ihr alles
was jemand nicht klar ist wann ja die
koseform von ivan ist in dieser
geschichte eine metapher für russland
und der böse kolja ist die ukraine und
alles was russland will ist der ukraine
den stock weg zu nehmen mit anderen
worten keine invasion keine bonbons eine
reine friedensmission und das ist es was
die russischen kinder zu sehen bekommen
handelt es sich um indoktrination nun
das können wir ruhig später in den
kommentaren diskutieren wichtig ist
jetzt dass wir uns das narrativ ansehen
dass die russischen kinder erreicht und
die frage ist wenn so was schon auf
kinder losgelassen wird was ist dann
erst mit den russischen erwachsenen los
nun das werden wir uns erst ansehen
der informationskrieg
[Musik]
seit jahren belegt ladepunkten
scheibchenweise und schritt für schritt
russland auf ein zunehmend autoritäre
system zu gut er hat noch nicht ganz das
niveau nordkoreas erreicht
aber das hier ist das russische
fernsehen
wie du sehen kannst die das russische
fernsehen so aus wie das fernsehen in
jedem anderen demokratischen land
zumindest auf den ersten blick sie haben
ihre nachrichtensendungen ihre
politischen talkshows und sogar
gediegenen late night talk tatsächlich
erlaubte der kreml bis märz diesen
jahres sogar einigen westlichen medien
in russland tätig zu sein sowohl die bbc
als auch radio free europe sind medien
die von der britischen bzw der
us-amerikanischen regierung finanziert
werden und pro westliche nachrichten auf
russisch senden im gegenzug erlaubt
europa die ausstrahlung von russia today
und sputnik es war so etwas wie ein
stilles übereinkommen wir akzeptieren
ihre propaganda in unserem land wenn ihr
uns erlaubt das gleiche in eurem land zu
tun mit dem krieg hat sich das alles
geändert
[Musik]
europa hat russia today und sputnik news
geblockt woraufhin russland mit der
abschaltung von radio free europe und
der dbc konterte aber wir reden nicht
nur über informationskrieg wir können
lange darüber diskutieren inwieweit ist
gut oder schlecht ist putins propaganda
medien in europa zu erlauben aber das
ist eine debatte für ein anderes video
denn heute konzentrieren wir uns auf die
russischen medien in russland und die
wahrheit ist dass der kreml sich nicht
darauf beschränkt westlichen medien
abzuschalten die zensur seit jahren
scheibchenweise eingeführt greift nun
überall um sich und hat nun ihren
totalitären charakter erreicht bis märz
dieses jahres gab es in russland zum
beispiel sogar einige kremlkritischen
fernsehsender okay es handelt es sich
nicht um viele und sie wurden immer
wieder durch die behörden drangsaliert
zum beispiel mit geldstrafen aber der
kreml ließ immerhin ein wenig kritik in
die medien zu quasi als feigenblatt so
war es zum beispiel im fall von echo
moskwy auf deutsch ich hoffe und moskau
ein radiosender der sogar den
gazprom-konzern gehört ja das stimmt
innerhalb russlands ist gastraum auch
ein medienkonzern auf jeden fall war
echo moskwy einer jener radiosender die
putin am kritischsten gegenüberstanden
sie hatten es geschafft in einem
zunehmend autoritären regimes überleben
aber das neue presse gesetzt dass der
themen gerade verabschiedet hat hat die
spielregeln grundsätzlich verändert
russischer liberale radiosender echo
moskwy schließt nachdem er vom netz
genommen wurde wenn wir die politischen
systeme verschiedenen länder analysieren
machen wir oft einen großen fehler wir
denken nur dualistische unterscheiden im
grunde nur zwei kategorien demokratie
oder diktatur in wirklichkeit bilder
autoritarismus aber ein breites spektrum
feine abstufungen auch im westen gibt es
zum teil starke tendenzen
nichtregierungs konformen meinungen zu
diskreditieren meiner meinung nach viel
zu stark es handelt sich um einen ewigen
kampf aber noch haben wir alles solide
grundlage um ihn zu führen wenn ich kann
es ja stolz wegen seiner comics und
wirecard verstrickung kritisiere muss
sich nur angst davor haben deswegen
zensiert oder gar vergiftet zu werden
aber wir müssen aufpassen bei manchen
themen wie corona oder jetzt der ukraine
trick schlägt die angst schnell in
hysterie um die alle schichten der
bevölkerung von der politik über die
medien bis zur normalen bürger umfasst
diese hysterie kann schnell in
pauschalen hass umschlagen zum beispiel
jetzt gegen großen allgemeinen vor
derartigen pauschalisierung müssen wir
uns unbedingt hüten denn
würden sich irgendwann wieder gegen uns
und unsere werte selbst richten es gibt
millionen gutherziger und aufgeklärter
großen die gegenpunkte in uns einer
gewalt sind und diese meinung sogar sehr
mutig vertreten obwohl ihnen hatte
strafen drohen ihnen muss unsere größte
unterstützung gelten denn sie sind die
einzige hoffnung dass russland nicht zu
einem nordkorea wird gut nordkorea ist
ein extremfall russland ist noch nicht
ganz so weit gekommen aber die tendenz
ist eindeutig sowohl die stimmung die
geschwitzt wird als auch die nun
erlassene gesetze stellen große schritte
in richtung diktatur dar
damit ihr euch ein bild machen könnt von
nun an muss jede russische journalist
der ein wenig vom drehbuch des kremls
abweichen mit einer gefängnisstrafe von
bis zu 15 jahren rechnen ich meine wir
reden hier nicht von einer geldstrafe
oder davon dass du von einem arbeitgeber
entlassen oder auf twitter geblockt wird
sondern von 15 jahren im harten russen
knast im moment verbreiten also alle
russischen fernsehsender die in der
vergangenheit als legitim und
pluralistisch gedrückt haben und auf die
russische bevölkerung nach wie vor
wirken dieselbe botschaft
nach dem russischen ratti für die ganze
ukraine durch nazis gelenkt und der oper
nazi ist wolodimir selensky der übrigens
jüdischer abstammung ist
gut aber was sind daran etwas dran wäre
gibt es in der ukraine tatsächlich nazis
die antwort darauf lautet natürlich ja
in einem land mit 44 millionen menschen
welche seit 100 jahren darum kämpft
überhaupt als eigenständige und
unabhängige nation respektiert zu werden
ja zu überleben gibt es
verständlicherweise etwas mehr patrioten
also in einem land dessen existenz
gesichert ist und dessen existenz er
recht nichts von einem übermächtigen
nachbarn dauernd infrage gestellt wird
und diese patrioten bilden natürlich ein
breites spektrum aus welches von
sozialisten über liberale demokraten bis
zur radikalen neonazis reicht viele der
ukrainischen neonazis entstammen den
milliardär fußball kollegen trafen sich
regelmäßig mit ihren russischen pondorf
um sich zusammen zu besoffen dem anderen
eins aufs maul hauen und danach wieder
in ideologische kameradschaft
heimzugehen ein ritual das aus vielen
anderen ländern kennen und ja auch in
russland gibt es jede menge neonazis
welche von der regierung unterstützt und
hofiert werden es besteht jedoch ein
großer unterschied zwischen der
behauptung es gebe in der ukraine ein
paar neonazi gruppen und der behauptung
dass sich das gesamte ukrainische
territorium in den händen von nazi
watt-regionen befände und deshalb hat
die russische propaganda einen doppelten
diskurs den ausländischen zuschauern
präsentiert sie nachrichten die man sich
von russia today oder sputnik kennt die
mainstream medien haben ebenfalls
übersehen dass das of waterloo dass ein
offizieller bestandteil der kiewer
streitkräfte ist eine pro nazi ideologie
vertritt wie du siehst ist dies eine
relativ glaubwürdige nachricht selbst
für jemanden der in einem land mit
meinungsfreiheit lebt ich meine gibt es
neonazi bataillone in der ukraine die in
der vergangenheit verbrechen gegen die
russischsprachige bevölkerung verübt
haben ja die gibt es werden diese durch
die regierung selensky unterstützt ja
das werden sie na dann ist ja alles klar
es handelt sich um ein nazi regime und
es ist vollkommen legitim es zu stürzen
notfalls mit gewalt von außen aber so
einfach ist das ganze nun mal nicht was
die russische propaganda hier tut ist
ganz bewusst einen wahren kern zu nehmen
und diesen dann mit jeder menge des
informationen zu vermengen so dass eine
klare unterscheidung zwischen wahrheit
und lüge nicht mehr möglich ist es ist
das alte motto des nazi
propagandaministers joseph goebbels man
müsste nur genügend dreck werfen egal ob
wahr oder nicht irgendwas bleibe immer
hängen allerdings sollten wir damit
dieser kreatur nicht zu viel ehre
zukommen lassen auch er hat nur
abgekupfert denn schon die alten römer
wussten sagte calum jahre selber liquid
herre thema feste verlangten es wird
schon was hängen bleiben fakt ist 2014
als putin die krim um den john war es
besetzen ließ war die armee der ukraine
in einem vollkommen desolaten zustand
wir haben darüber in einem früheren
video berichtet obendrein waren alle
verteidigungsanlagen noch aus dem kalten
krieg ging westen ausgerichtet die
ukraine also gar nicht darauf
vorbereitet dass die russen ihr aus dem
osten in den rücken fallen würden
dermaßen kalt erwischt hatte sie damals
nicht gerade den luxus nicht genau
auszusuchen wer sich freiwillig so
landesverteidigung bereiterklärte man
musste nehmen was kommt und das regiment
asaf benannt nach dem asowschen meer war
nur eines von dutzenden
paramilitärischer freiwilligen
bataillone welche zu jeder zeit des
allergrößten verteidigungs und stand in
der ukraine entstanden sind
tatsächlich bilden asus kern damals jede
erwähnten fußball ultras und üblen
neonazis den schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen im rahmen
ihrer kämpfe gegen die russischen
eindringlinge und separatisten
vorgeworfen werden nachdem sich jedoch
der anfänglichen schock gelegt hatte und
die größte not gelindert war wurde auf
das sich insbesondere bei der
verteidigung mario polls große
militärische verdienste erworben hatte
so wie die anderen freiwilligen
bataillone in die reguläre ukrainische
national gerade ein gegliedert so dass
wieder staatliche aufsicht über dieses
chaos an kampfgruppen einkehrt momentan
sieht es so aus als hätte dies erfolg
gehabt die meisten extremisten verließen
das regiment und heute zählt ist nur
noch 900 mitglieder
[Musik]
es stellt somit gerade mal zwei promille
der gesamten ukrainischen streitkräfte
da und diese zwei promille fascher mücke
bläst die russische propaganda bis heute
zu einem riesigen nase elefanten auf
auch sonst spielt der rechtsextremismus
in der ukrainischen gesellschaft und
politik kaum eine rolle waren 2014
ultranationalisten noch an der regierung
beteiligt erhielten sie bei den letzten
parlamentswahlen im jahr 2019 gerade mal
2,15 prozent der stimmen die
überwiegende mehrheit im trainer wählt
liberale parteien die um die mitte herum
angesiedelt sind und heute auch die
regierung stellen und allgemein versucht
die ukraine angesichts der
existenziellen bedrohung durch putin
alle kräfte in ihrer gesellschaft egal
ob rechts oder links ob ukraine oder
rose sprach ich zu integrieren statt zu
spalten und auszugrenzen denn wenn man
in den letzten wochen eines gesehen hat
dann wohl diese überragende einigkeit
der komplexen und multi ethnischen
ukrainischen gesellschaft gegen putins
des buddhismus und totalitarismus anders
als eine propaganda behauptet kann von
einer kontrolle der ukraine durch
rechtsextremisten also keine regel seien
es ist eher umgekehrt die freiheitliche
orientierte ukraine hat ihre
rechtsextremisten recht gut unter
kontrolle gebracht trotzdem darf man
nicht vergessen dass es sich um eine
riskante gratwanderung handelt man kann
auf die künftig auf der social nelly
truppe nicht ganz verzichten läuft
gefahr sich eine art bahn im lande
heranzuzüchten gut all diese tatsachen
und nuancen interessieren putins
propaganda medien natürlich nicht die
bohne die rhetorik auf allen kanälen ist
wie in dieser politischen talkshow
eindeutig geben das vorschiff demokrat
jerry brown
ist
schön hier falsch ist und natürlich
wirst du im russischen fernsehen auch
keine bilder von zerstörten ukrainischen
städten sehen und wenn dann wird dies
natürlich schamlos als berg der
ukrainischen nazis gegen die
russischsprachige bevölkerung gefragt es
wird kaum etwas über den beschuss von
städten gesagt und nichts über die
gezielte zerstörung ganzer wohnviertel
der zeuge wir alle im westen geworden
sind das vorgehen der russischen armee
war ständig als chirurgisch präzise
spezialoperationen die nur gegen nazis
und militärische ziele gerichtet wird
präsentiert und natürlich werden auch
die gewaltigen russischen verluste
verschwiegen und ich weiß was viele von
euch jetzt fragen warum will putin
eigentlich vor den russen verbergen dass
irland einen vollumfänglichen krieg
führt ich meine wurde die ganze
russische gesellschaft nicht jahrelang
gezielt militarisiert und mental auf
krieg getrimmt warum dachten selbst
viele soldaten den ersten tagen der
invasion sie würden noch immer an einer
übung teilnehmen wäre es nicht
sinnvoller dem volk all die ehrfurcht
gebietenden aktionen der glorreichen
russischen armee zu zeigen mit welchen
sie die ukraine in den boden rammt nun
das wäre es sicher nicht und wir werden
gleich sehen warum
reden ist krieg krieg ist frieden
es mag vielleicht überraschen aber es
ist nicht das erste mal dass der kreml
einen seiner kriege massiv vertuscht
während ihrer invasion afghanistans in
den 1980 er jahren hat die sowjetunion
alles daran gesetzt um das wort krieg in
den medien zu vermeiden in diesem fall
war im offiziellen sprachgebrauch stadt
von krieg von internationaler hilfe die
rede eine derartige sprachliche
verschleierung hat für ihre urheber
nämlich gleich mehrere vorteile überlegt
mal kriege jagen leuten nicht nur angst
ein sondern man kann sie auch verlieren
aber sondereinsätzen oder internationale
interventionen sind viel unbestimmte
begriffe und auch ihr ausgang kann viel
leichter verwaschen und propagandistisch
uminterpretiert werden anders
ausgedrückt im gegensatz zu den
amerikanern haben die soll jetzt nie
miterlebt wie ihre armee afghanistan in
demütigung verlassen musste man kann ein
krieg nicht verlieren wenn man niemandem
den krieg erklärt hat
[Musik]
aber das ist nicht der einzige grund
warum der creme die aktuellen krieg
vertuschen will sie ist folgendermaßen
seit jahren schon führt putin
militarismus und patriotischer
begeisterung in der russischen
bevölkerung in früheren visual politik
videos haben wir euch gezeigt wie er da
eine kathedrale für das militär
errichten ließ extremen nationalismus
militarismus und welt eroberungs
fantasieren sind auch in der russischen
popkultur omnipräsent falls ihr ein
bisschen tiefer in die zeitgenössische
russische kultur eintauchen möchten
empfehle ich sich zum beispiel die hard
bass musik also russischen techno
anzuhören in russland gibt es die
sogenannten komplex die ihre eigene
subkultur haben wenn ihr euch diese
erste musik anhört findet ihre texte die
feier wie darlehen oder russland ist
mein mutterland und ja diese songs sind
keine randerscheinungen sondern werden
ganz normal in jeder russischen disco
gespielt
[Musik]
und patriotismus findet sich was über
all die die jetzt sagen aber es gibt
einen großen unterschied zwischen den
russischen und zum beispiel dem
amerikanischen oder französischen
patriotismus
[Musik]
journalismus forscher unterscheiden zwei
arten von patriotismus den
staatsbürgerlichen und den ethnischen
der bürgerliche patriotismus basiert auf
einer gemeinsamen idee aufwerten und
lebensweise die usa oder die ehemalige
sowjetunion deren beispiel für diesen
bürgerlichen nationalismus dies so wie
jetzt egal ob russen ukrainer oder
kasachen kämpft nicht für den ruhm
russlands lagern für die proletarische
revolution aber was ist die ideologie
russlands heute wofür steht eigentlich
putin nun leider erschwert uns eine
gewisse sprachbarriere diese problematik
auf die schnelle zu begreifen im
deutschen kennt ihr die begriffe
russisch russland und russische
föderation und das alles klingt für uns
irgendwie gleich auf russisch heißt ist
jedoch einerseits kasties kassel razia
und rasierer und andererseits fuß und
tasci alle menschen in russland sind
kastanie und das grösste ethnische
segment unter ihnen sind eben die russki
es gibt daneben aber noch viele andere
tataren tschetschenen marschieren und so
weiter putin hat in seinen öffentlichen
reden bisher immer von asiana gesprochen
um die balance zwischen den
verschiedenen ethnien zu halten rückt
allerdings in den letzten jahren immer
mehr die mehrheit den narr oscar in den
vordergrund das heißt ein fokus ganz
klar auf das russische kern volk
gerichtet auch wenn er sich nicht
unbedingt mit den übrigen medien
verscherzen will und auch keine
unnötigen konflikte innerhalb russlands
provozieren möchte er begründet den
russischen nationalismus deswegen auch
immer stärker auf einem sprachlichen
ethnischen konzept die große islamische
nation angeführt von den rose sprechen
und sich selbst stilisiert putin eben
als absoluten schutzpatron all dieser
russisch sprechenden menschen im
wahrsten sinne rund um die welt als ein
schutzpatron der diese zur not eben auch
mit zu schützen müsse nach diesem
konzept sind auch ukrainer und russen
bruder völker putin hat die selbst
mehrfach erklärt schließlich leben
großen ukraine schon seit jahrhunderten
zusammen es gibt millionen von ukrainer
die in russland leben und tausende von
mischehen ivan normal russe hat auf der
krim schon immer urlaub gemacht hat von
der itf und spricht sogar ein paar worte
ukrainisch und das erklärt dass
schlagzeilen wie diese navalny fordert
der osten auf täglich gegen den
einmarsch in die ukraine zu protestieren
für diejenigen die nicht in alexei
navalny ist putins größter politischer
widersacher und zurzeit sitzen auch
viele tausende von russen im gefängnis
weil sie an anti kriegs teams
teilgenommen haben aber wir dürfen uns
keine illusionen hergeben diese proteste
sind nicht unbedingt prowestlich
[Musik]
na weil diese es ist ebenfalls nach
journalist und der russischen
nationalismus basiert auf der idee dass
die ukraine brüder der russen sind doch
jetzt tötet die russische armee ukraina
das ist eine völlig andere situation als
bei der besetzung der krim ich meine
2014 als russland auf der halbinsel krim
einmarschierte gab es kaum opfer zu
beklagen putin nahm sie ein ohne einen
schuss abzufeuern die situation ist
jetzt vollkommen anders und viele russen
die durch und durch nationalisten sind
fragen sich nun warum schlachten wir
unsere eigenen brüder ab
[Musik]
life balls zum beispiel ist ein youtube
kanal der von einem russen gegründet
wurde und auf dem er über die russische
kultur spricht als der nicht krieg in
der ukraine ausbrach beschloss boris
sich mit diesen worten zu verabschieden
ich habe familie freunde und verwandte
die sowohl in der ukraine als auch in
russland leben ich würde gerne sagen
können dass sich alle die ich kenne in
sicherheit befinden aber das wäre eine
lüge deswegen muss putin vorsichtig sein
und erst einmal verbergen dass es diesen
krieg gibt im grunde geht er nach einem
gewohnten muster vor vor der annexion
erklimmen und der abspaltung des dollars
im jahr 2014 waren seine
popularitätswerte stark gesunken er
brauchte also einen nationalistischen
triumph und siehe da die zustimmung für
ihn schnellte auf 70 bis 80 prozent und
auch vor der jetzigen invasion in der
ukraine bewegte sich jedoch und wieder
nur noch etwas über 50% putin weiß
jedoch dass er mit einem erfolgreichen
facebook die ihr das volle potenzial von
70 bis 80 prozent ausschöpfen kann dazu
braucht er nur zwei dinge einen krieg
und perfektes fremming so dass er ihn
als nationalen triumph über das böse
ausgeben und die ganzen wirtschaftlichen
folgen in russland von ungarns auf den
bösen westen schieben kann sozusagen als
zusätzlicher beweis dass dieser das
russische volk knechten und zerstören
wolle genau auf dieses negativ ist die
russische propaganda ausgerichtet und
man muss sagen dass sie damit auch
großen erfolg hat den meisten in
russland lebenden russen bis die
britische version der wahrheit allemal
lieber als auf zu begehen und nachteile
und strafen zu riskieren oder sich sogar
eingestehen zu müssen dass man sich
nicht dagegen ausspricht dass die eigene
armee ein bruder volk abschlachtet
selbst menschen die familienangehörige
in der ukraine haben glauben er dem
russischen fernsehen als diesen es ist
bequemer für sie die augen vor der
wahrheit zu verschließen putin kennt
seine pappenheimer und liefert ihnen ein
überaus komfortablen gesinnungs rahmen
gesprächen hierüber immerhin 80 bis 100
millionen menschen auf ihren
ungebrochene unterstützung sich sein
regime stützt das ist eine immense
machtbasis alle fantasien über putin
sturz die jetzt überall in den köpfen
von politikern und experten kursieren
müssen von diesen realen rahmen bewertet
werden denn viele andere diktatoren mit
einer viel schwächeren machtbasis haben
geschafft sich trotz massiver sanktionen
druck aus dem ausland und sogar
militärische niederlagen über jahrzehnte
an der macht zu halten fidel castro
saddam hussein und die kim-dynastie
nordkorea sind nur die prominentesten
beispiele die preisfrage lautet also ob
es überhaupt möglich sein wird diese
perfide maskerade zu durchbrechen denn
auch wenn putin nicht ewig in der lage
sein wird den krieg in seinem vollen
ausmaß vor den russen zu verbergen wie
werden sie überhaupt mit diesen
unbequemen wahrheiten umgehen wollen
aber was glaubt ihr wie lange putins
propaganda strategie funktionieren wird
und wie könnte man sie durchbrechen wie
immer sind auch eure beiträge und
diskussionen zu diesem wichtigen thema
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat mir dabei
vielleicht auch etwas gelernt habe 20
jahre gibt uns mit einleitenden freunden
und vergesst nicht dass aber mit glück
noch keines unserer videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch
mittels hält dieses projekt und
weiterzuführen denn peter link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung oder dem
video machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]